well we continue with our national
teacher appreciation effort yeah we
stopped in at myrtle tate elementary
school where the principal has chosen an
outstanding teacher to spotlight this
week
clara chambers started her teaching
career at myrtle tate elementary school
where she's been shaping the lives of
kindergartners for the past eight years
five-year-olds make me laugh
they love to learn i turn off the faucet
while i rush
she is a phenomenal kindergarten teacher
the energy and passion that she brings
to her classroom each day is unmatched
principal sarah popett adds the work
clara does outside the classroom equally
important she also tutors english
language learners after school she has
about 20 students many of them whom are
newcomers
to the united states those are the
students that make the most growth
honestly
from no english to
speaking complete sentences by the end
of the school year clara loves to make
connections with the students and their
families that adoration sparked when she
was in high school volunteering for an
elementary school teacher miss minna is
her name
i owe it to her because of her i
developed my passion for kids and
teaching and now she gets to pay it
forward with a student teacher of her
own i feel fortunate enough to be able
to
help her and assist her and provide her
with the knowledge because i know what
it's like to be a first time teacher